a whole bunch of people emailed me about
CNN's Anderson Cooper interviewing the
Mayor of Las Vegas Nevada Carolyn
Goodman
and it is something else so I want to
look at a few clips with you
Anderson was visibly stunned by how
ignorant and incompetent the mayor of
Las Vegas is how she got to become mayor
of Las Vegas is a different story but
let's look at some of the interview and
Carolyn Goodman is desperate for Las
Vegas to open up this includes casinos
this includes the Las Vegas Strip in
general but she doesn't actually have
any idea how it could happen safely
other than to wildly dismiss every
concern that Anderson Cooper brings up
and say that listen they're going to
have to figure it out let's get right
into it there's a Chinese researchers
have shown how this virus spreads I just
want to put up her new words I just want
to put up our viewers this is a arrest
Nevada Wow okay that's really ignorant
this is a restaurant and the yellow
statement that's that's a restaurant and
yes it's in China but there are human
beings too that's yellow is a person who
is asymptomatic and infected and all
those other red circles or other diners
who that one diner passed the virus to
all those other people became infected
in a restaurant that had air
conditioning and they believed it was
the air conditioning which Pat helped
the virus and spread to all those other
remember the Legionnaires disease in
1976 in Philadelphia came all through
the air conditioning you don't remember
because you're younger I don't marry
typhoid mary who I think passed away
well anyway during the late 30s rode the
buses was a cook and she was
asymptomatic and she spreaded a fear of
getting typhoid and she never showed the
sign of it and she lived most of her
life quarantine the reality was I think
58 people passed away from typhoid and
so we're aware of this we learned from
history we've had Ebola we've had them
West night
but we've had polio we've had these none
of those were as infectious in Las Vegas
I mean you didn't have people with Ebola
on a casino floor you know what if you
don't know that well yet you do because
if you had a neighbor mine died from
West Nile yeah her neighbor died of West
Nile she has no idea what she's talking
about listing other diseases isn't
anything it's not an argument it's not a
reason to do anything it's not a reason
not to do anything Legionnaires in the
1970s what is this woman talking about
and it continues and it actually gets
even worse you're you're talking about
encouraging hundreds of thousands of
people to come to Las Vegas I get the
the financial losses people are
suffering which is awful but you're
encouraging I mean hundreds of thousands
of people coming there in casinos
smoking drinking touching slot machines
breathing circulated air and then
returning home to states around America
and countries around the world doesn't
that sound like a virus petri dish I
mean how is that know what it sounds
like you're being an alarmist I'm not
I've lived a long life I grew up in the
heart of Manhattan I know what it's like
to be with subways and on buses and
elevators I think you are by saying what
you have just said so you don't believe
there should be any social distancing
you don't believe there should be no
that's up to them to figure out so it
got really really bad and I would
encourage you to check out the full
interview on YouTube on CNN's website
now the one thing I can say about
Carolyn Goodman is she looks remarkably
good for being an 81 year old woman I
would not have guessed she was 81 by any
means so congratulations to her maybe
some of that dry Vegas heat is helping
her remain extremely spry into her 80s
other than that I don't have much
positive that I can really say about her
and there's an interesting thing
happening where as the world does become
more and more focused on slowing down
the spread of coronavirus and most of
the planet understands what were five
here and why we're doing it in
comparison the crazy people are getting
a lot louder the anti lockdown
protesters around the country seem
completely out of it I mean blocking
traffic and making it difficult for
ambulances to bring patients who need
medical care to a hospital it's crazy
Carolyn Goodman as mayor of Las Vegas
seems completely disconnected from
reality at this point when someone like
Carolyn Goodman doesn't deal in fact but
just abstractly talks about the economy
opening up and ignores the issue of the
virus spread itself they are essentially
saying I don't care who lives or dies
but we need to get money flowing it's
the embrace of what I talked about on
Wednesday maybe it was Tuesday
Republicans embracing let them die let
them die in exchange for whatever
they've identified as a higher priority
this is the approach that they're taking
most people aren't going to fall for it
and yesterday I pointed out mayor's
can't really open cities governors can't
really open states the president can't
really open the country it's up to the
people to do it and in the case of Las
Vegas even if it quote opened there
aren't many flights coming in and out
foreign flights are almost completely
cut off most people recognize that a
crowded pacy casino even if it's open
even if you could go and sit down at a
blackjack table and get the free drinks
brought to you and the entire thing most
people recognize that it doesn't make
sense to do that right now so even if
she opens Vegas it's not going to be
much of an opening and I think that
that's an important thing to remember
regardless of the at increasingly
astroturfed
protests to reopen polling shows that
most Americans are prioritizing slowing
the spread over saving the economy and
I'm not saying the economic destruction
is not significant we now have 26
million people who in five weeks have
filed new unemployment insurance claims
I'm right there with you but over the
medium and long term we are better off
if we don't have resurgence of the virus
because of opening too early Carolyn
Goodman doesn't seem to understand that
and a stunning interview I encourage you
to check out in total let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we
a fantastic program planned for you
today